so yesterday I told you that our
president was calling for the
deportation of suspected undocumented
immigrants with no judges with no trials
and in that story I explained that that
would not be constitutional this all
started because Donald Trump a couple of
days ago went to Twitter and said we
cannot allow all of these people to
invade our country when somebody comes
in we must immediately with no judges or
court cases bring them back from where
they came and as grammatically bizarre
as that is what he is saying is that we
would eliminate due process for certain
people and even though I explained in
the video that due process applies to
undocumented immigrants that there is
some debate as to whether every element
of the Constitution and Bill of Rights
applies to undocumented immigrants that
much of the Constitution in the Bill of
Rights refers to all persons within the
borders of the United States I said it
in the video I knew that people would
come to me and say David they're not
citizens so the Constitution doesn't
apply or the Bill of Rights doesn't
apply so I went out of my way to explain
why it does and unfortunately tons of
right-wingers wrote to me tweeted to me
commented on YouTube that these are not
citizens and therefore the Constitution
doesn't apply to them and what Donald
Trump said is absolutely fine here are
just some examples here's three YouTube
comments that we received one said I may
be mistaken but I think the Constitution
is only for citizens of the United
States so therefore they have no rights
under our Constitution that doesn't
rightfully belong to them another
commenter on YouTube said simply lies
lies lies David Pakman is not an honest
person and one more example from YouTube
they are illegals they are not citizens
of the USA therefore they have no rights
under the USA's constitution so I want
to be crystal clear with you today this
is not a question of whether due process
should apply to undocumented immigrants
this is merely a quest
of whether due process does apply to
undocumented immigrants or to frame in a
different way it's not about what you
want it to be it's about what it is the
facts of whether due process desert
doesn't apply to undocumented immigrants
don't care about your feelings and
courts have held time and time and time
again that anybody on US soil is
protected by the constitutional right to
due process whether they came in legally
or illegally to the United States now
there is a difference and I have no urge
to obfuscate there is a difference
between people in the country and people
at the border okay it is true that there
are somewhat more limited procedures
that have been okayed by courts for
Congress to put in place if they want
for non-citizens detained at the border
but the law and the courts have been
unquestionably clear that anyone ordered
to leave has recourse to appeal their
deportation through a process that
involves a court and a judge they can be
represented by a lawyer period now for
those saying well in certain cases there
should be a faster process for getting
these people out and actually that
exists already and again it's not about
whether you like it or not or what you
want it to be it's about what it is and
there is a process called expedited
removal which in some situations applies
it applies to undocumented immigrants
found within a hundred miles of the
border typically the circumstances in
which Border Patrol operates and within
fourteen days of entering the country
and that already is the law and the
Trump administration could try to use it
more often and the expedited removal can
also be avoided by the undocumented
individual seeking asylum and this
asylum element is also a big part of
what's going on at the border and this
brings up another piece of just fact
that a lot of people either don't know
or are ignoring which is that entering
the country illegally is a misdemeanor
the first time that you do it it is not
a felony if you do it again if you
become a repeat offender it does become
a felony that
is also really important and relevant
when we think about what recourse is
available depending on the specific
circumstances the first time coming into
the United States illegally is a
misdemeanor but the most important part
of this that I want to repeat is that
this is actually not a debate over what
these laws should be you can have that
debate but right now this is the law and
there's lots of right wingers that are
getting into the debate around whether
or not there should be due process
protections under the Constitution or
Bill of Rights and Bill of Rights for
undocumented immigrants they might say I
don't want immigrants to get to process
or it should be legal to send them out
immediately with no judge or trial or
the current system rewards criminality
whatever argument they want to make they
can make it based on their feelings but
that is not the law and that is the
really important thing that is not being
said and even people I mean I'm guessing
they just commented without watching our
video I know yeah well you know how
sometimes in the Constitution there are
things that are deliberately vague it
seems like the Second Amendment you
could say you know on the one hand it
says well-regulated militia on the other
hand it says shall not be infringed so
we could have a discussion there but the
Fifth Amendment says no person right so
the Due Process Clause the Fifth
Amendment that stuff's very clear and
the courts have decided that and the
Constitution and Bill of Rights
sometimes use the word citizens and
sometimes they don't and if we believe
in this pseudo religious adherence to
the founding fathers writing of the
Constitution then we should understand
that they must have met something
different when they wrote citizens and
when they wrote all persons and there's
lots of Trumpets who seem to be confused
about whether we're discussing what they
want to be the law versus what is the
law and the law as it currently exists
directly contradicts the suspension of
due process that Trump is proposing here
if the Constitution is your guiding
principle this de-facto religious
document for the constitutional
fetishists then the debate should
actually be around ensuring that the
Constitution is adhered to but instead
the same self proclaimed constitutional
fetishists are trying to find a way are
around what the Constitution says to
serve their goals in this particular
case I think some people are gonna think
that this is a repeat show you tried to
preempt some of my by saying that you
know the Constitution is pretty clear on
this but it didn't seem to work it's
almost like people are making comments
and emailing me and tweeting based just
on the titles of videos and not after
actually having watched them I know that
might come as a huge shock to some
people in the audience but it seems to
be going on